we're gonna stick with the story here in
Charleston South Carolina that has a lot
of meaning to the people here
it's the Emanuel AME Church right here
right down the road from us it's a
symbol of resilience and hope and nearly
five years ago we all know this story in
June of 2015 a white supremacist shot
and killed nine worshippers at the
historic church known for its political
activism Dylan roof was convicted in
2016 of all 33 federal charges including
hate crimes we visited the church over
the weekend it's known as mother Emanuel
to see how it's turning tragedy into
action we also spoke to House Majority
Whip james Clyburn who is expected to
endorse former Vice President Joe Biden
Joe Biden rather after this debate he
showed us how the church has become a
base camp in the fight for change this
is of course the sanctuary it's
beautiful Reverend Eric Manning oversees
mother Emanuel the oldest black
congregation south of Baltimore
[Music]
a church that has been involved in
nearly every political movement since
its founding in 1816 Reverend Manning
started leading this congregation about
a year after the shooting death of nine
parishioners including the beloved
pastor clementa pinckney how difficult
was it for you I would imagine so many
people leaned on you to bring them back
to a new normal
I must confess Kelly I think that
process is still going on we never
really fully understand the amount of
trauma a church especially within the
african-american community experiences
when that type of hatred is displayed a
hatred that 75 year-old Polly shepherd
knows all too well you were probably one
of the few that actually had a
conversation was Dylan roof that day
yeah where were you I was under the
table and looking up at there you saw
him approaching yeah I could see issues
I don't dirty temperament boots they
came up and asked me did I shoot you yet
and that's it no they say I'm not going
to I'm gonna leave you here to tell a
story one of the things that was so
extraordinary about this horrible
tragedy is that many people in the
church seemed to forgive very quickly
were you one of those people I wasn't
the first one I was busy at home feeling
sorry for myself
yeah you know it's a little why why did
you leave me to think about all of this
you had no guilt for surviving I did
I've heard that you would like to
minister him in prison is that true I
would what would you say to him I would
go strictly by the Bible and go in there
to forget in this part and this teach
him how love is you said that to heal
you have to forgive ya have you forgiven
have you healed
[Music]
where do you think we are as a country
as we sit here today
well racism is still alive and well
that's the fact I don't know what we can
do but when things happen then we all
come together mm-hmm but after a while
we go back to the same old things we've
been doing career in politics intersect
often at mother Emanuel on this day a
political movement is taking shape in
the church's basement the site of the
horrific mass shooting if you ever run
for office that's where we met House
Majority Whip james Clyburn who's
lending his political expertise to the
Congressional Black Caucus Institute
workshop why do you think this type of
training is necessary to empower the the
future black politicians well I think
one of the big mistakes we make
especially in my party is not
recognizing that there's talent in the
african-american community beyond that
which is traditional and in order to
make sure that we get beyond tradition
is one of the reasons that we saw the
boot camp the nonpartisan political boot
camp aims to improve access to advocacy
in campaign training for all Americans
free of charge what do you hope that
they learn during that time well we're
hopeful that they will learn that
politics is more than a science to be
studied it is an art to be practiced
because you never perfect the odds how
are you as congressman Clyburn helps
build a future pipeline of politicians
South Carolina's kingmaker sounds off on
the current Democratic field there are
no people of color on it does that
bother you
no it doesn't bother me we can't
guarantee success we can guarantee
opportunity and what the DNC did was
guarantee opportunity we started out
with a big number and that's one of the
reasons we had to boot camp teach people
how the fundraise because what got how
people of color out of this contest more
than anything else was being able to
afford
to get their message out here in South
Carolina 60% of Democratic voters are
black making this first in the South
primary a test of who can connect with
black voters South Carolina will tell a
very important story when the when that
vote comes in that's true South Carolina
is a very conservative state mm-hmm but
there's something about fundamentalist
fundamental fairness that you get in
South Carolinians you look through
history you never saw the acrimony in
South Carolina that you've got in
Mississippi Alabama
I like that fundamental fairness yeah
there's a fundamental fairness to
getting sacraments a state with a sense
of fundamental fairness a community
fighting against hatred and a sacred
space that embodies the power of
forgiveness what do you say to people
that say that are struggling with this
message of you know it's so divisive
it's so hateful the rhetoric is out
there what is your message to those
people I hate to say you have to learn
the next person communicate and try to
get along love is the answer to
everything
boy Polly Shepherd hopes to see a more
united country soon she says she thinks
that some of the divisive rhetoric is
coming from the top down she doesn't
know who she will vote for yet she says
she might make a spur-of-the-moment
decision based on what she hears at
tonight's democratic debate she says she
will be watching and she also told us
guys that she has narrowed it down to
two candidates two and she's pretty sure
she's not sure which one of the two
she's really paying attention but I
thought she was an amazing remarkable
woman just the fact that she wants to go
to prison and Minister Dylan roof who
you know by the way is not shown any
remorse for the shooting yeah well you
know you talk about the divide in this
country I think if more people approach
their life the way Polly does there be a
lot less to this I can't imagine
carrying what she's carried for these
last five years and for her to be in the
place where she is is really it's really
impressive Gail thank you you're welcome